all right Janet is next in Los Angeles
hi Janet how are you I'm doing well
thank you for taking my call
sure I was wondering if we should stop
our contributions and baby steps four
and five because I'm afraid we're over
funding them
well you can't over fund baby step four
because by definition it's 15% of your
income are you putting on more than 15%
of your income towards retirement no but
I did I went to Chris Hogan's website
for and put in all of my numbers for the
riq and found out that if we did
absolutely nothing between now and
twenty five years from now when we can
actually touch the money in our 401ks
and IRAs that we'd actually have more I
think a million more than we actually
need based on what we're hoping to let's
draw out that play which is a great
feeling but I wouldn't maybe you don't
need to be put that's awesome I mean
you've obviously got a lot of money
going but then maybe you don't need to
put it in a 401 KS maybe just need to
invest it uh well we have a mortgage and
I would love to pay that off even
earlier and we also want to get into
real estate and then that's a way to do
it is to start putting 15% away in a
mutual fund um that's how I've done my
real estate I just used like a no load
SP 500 and I just throw money in there
and you could do that you could do your
15% that way and when that gets big
enough buy a piece of real estate with
it for cash okay um and you know fifteen
percent or so the house is paid off if
you want to do that that's okay I mean
how much have you got your 401ks
combined we've got four hundred and
sixty thousand and how old are you 34
okay um yeah I'm going to continue to
save fifteen percent of your income
what's your household income about it's
variable but it's about 250 now you're
killing it
okay here's the use though here's the
funny thing here's the fun thing in five
years
none of this discussions can matter
because you will
done all of this because you ran yeah
your ratio of income is just so stinking
high you're killing it what do y'all do
for a living
my husband's a small business and I'm
also self-employed well congratulations
very very well done you're winning so
here's the thing it doesn't matter as
long as you do both eventually and
eventually means in the next five years
so if you want to go your plan and just
stop and pay off the house boom you're
done but if you do our plan and put 15%
away in mutual funds and someday buy
real estate with that and it's not the
401k and you're still gonna have your
house paid off in five years okay
because you're just making so much and
and regarding the kids college funds
wait we've got three and a five year old
and about forty four for the two of them
I'm just okay I wasn't sure if we yeah
wherever come okay what yeah what I did
there is I funded it for a while and
when I looked up and realized it was
like crazy
and our income went way up like yours is
done right I just looked over on I'm on
cash flow college and I ended up giving
them their college funds when they
graduated high school and so you know I
worked out you know when they you know
when they came out they were like real
adults and you know Pinocchio is like a
real boy and all that so you know we
just did that so your if you could
maintain this income track you're on
you'll cashflow college I'm not worried
about college at all so Wow pretty cool
huh yeah I know investments you can
invest in Chris Brown it's a new - new
no it's not I'm already invested in this
yes you are
that's awesome this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in
you